I got a question do you consider
yourself high value as a woman oh no no
because right we talk about high value
men no no why why I think that like if I
had to pick like a high value but I
think I'm cute you know but I don't
think not on looks I'm not talking about
looks but okay this is my opinion okay
we say what what is your sexual
Marketplace value that's based on looks
okay because women don't say I'm a 10.
it's like no no we're not talking about
how you feel we're talking about how you
look okay right
um and then the total Marketplace value
is like you as a person your character
your loyalty you know you as a human
being your values there so I'd say
overall not just looks okay I'm talking
about as a person because when we talk
about high value what do me what what do
high value men want in a woman you tell
me oh I'm in like feminine friendly I
would say is the the right ideal woman
loyal yeah uh the support role right see
I mean I guess um I I am really loyal to
be honest like I'm a very loyal person
but the thing is I just think high value
I think that is like top five percent
ten percent of people and I just
wouldn't say I'm like five ten percent
are you wiping material I I like to
think so okay I think you'd have to be
married to be wifey material okay but
are you are you potential wifey yeah I
think so okay so when you rate yourself
I always say you say you're average yeah
I do okay but in the value area you're
high value
because you bring a lot of value yeah
right because that's the problem right I
tell guys look you can't turn a hoe into
a housewife right you can but they'll
get married but they'll end up being
divorced right because we talk about
that right because that's the first
thing guys do is they go for looks but
then it's like what's the other side of
the fence look like right are you with
me yeah so okay good deal and what is uh
my question I had somebody who is Pearl
Davis how would you describe yourself
how would I describe myself
um
well
funnier
you would think I'd have a good answer
to that it's a tough one isn't it yeah
um I mean I'm really family oriented so
I really love my family
um I miss I hate being so far from them
right now actually
um do you see them often not as often as
I'd like since I moved I used to live at
home before
um but no not as much anymore sadly but
you do you live in London downtown yeah
that's expensive yeah so you are balling
[Laughter]
um well I mean women we spend money with
like water right oh my gosh and and uh
what about what's some let's talk about
you're on your summer tour you talk
about some of the podcasts you've been
on you've been on valuetainment both of
them not the oh last time not this time
weren't you on Adam thought you isn't it
yeah but I wasn't on like this tour but
I a couple months ago I was so you've
been on Jedediah yes Adams on Valley
table yes you've been on Fresh have you
been on Fresh pit yeah two years ago
yeah okay you're a fresh and fit you
were on whatever yes uh who else am I
missing you got Andrew Tate how did that
happen
um his
his team reached out to me actually
really yeah I mean I've reached out to
him like ages before but then he got
banned on Instagram so it was gone but
yeah um my recruiter got a message from
um Andrew like sartorial shooter Andrew
Tate's friend oh okay yeah and so he
reached out and then
um I had the idea to bring Brittany
Renner on the show
yeah and I picked the girls and I had
Auntie on so that was oh my God are you
an auntie a good terms yeah yeah no oh
my gosh it was funny I was actually
supposed to go to Dubai I forgot about
this I was I bought everyone tickets to
go to Dubai we were supposed to do the
podcast there my passport expired within
six months Dubai doesn't let you in so I
actually lost like I probably lost like
ten fifteen thousand dollars yeah
yeah tripping shirts on anything I was
like oh my god wow most expensive
assistant of my life let me tell you but
but it was worth it still in the end and
having them on yeah because then he he
was so nice he came to London then and
then um I flew out Brittany Renner too
and she wouldn't have been on the panel
if we went to Dubai so I'm actually
really lucky it happened the way it did
so if you're if your passports expire
within six months you can't go to Dubai
nope that's what I learned I gotta get
my passport you can't use a emergency
passport either if anyone wants
really yes wow so so you so how did
things change after you had Andrew Tate
on your show oh my channel like took I
mean it was already
I mean I think we were at like 50 to 80
million views a month before but that
that month was crazy like I think we
went from 800 000 Subs to like 1.3 or 4
million wow yeah I mean off of that
train it was other stuff too but yeah I
got like I think I'm I got
maybe like 20 000 Subs in a day like the
day I dropped it it was like 60 000
people watching live I knew because I am
very good whenever I put together a
panel I'm always thinking like who are
the opposite of each other yeah you have
some Wild Ones on there that are so loud
nobody ever calls them out yes that's my
pet peeve it's like look you're single
because you're loud and obnoxious
yeah yeah I need to be meaner sometimes
and let's how okay another question how
many people have you kicked off your
your uh podcast oh my gosh you just had
another one
all right let me think
um that chick that was like a 19 year
old kid
um crazy lady the one that oh Esther
[Laughter]
um
didn't you have to call the police
oh yeah I forgot about the I forgot
about the was it four total we've kicked
off who's the fifth
I think it's five but I forget sometimes
but yeah I did have to call the police
on one lady threatened um King riches
who's like another YouTuber she like she
said yeah she was basically threatening
him and then this other one
um
this other one yeah called the police
and said we like assaulted her because I
saw that I saw that was she blonde no I
didn't think she was a brunette hey I
got a Super Chat would love to see Pearl
on The View
with oh oh 10 people that watch it I
would love to be on The View they should
help me on you think they would
maybe I've seen them some crazy guess
that I think they'd hate me they tried
to trap me but I'd be ready for it okay
so I got a deal everybody that's
watching this and I don't have the
following you who you have unless you
repost some of these you're gonna have
access to all the videos by the way so
you repost these clips so if you're
watching this podcast everybody watching
it today or tomorrow I want you to
contact the view and tell them that they
need to have Pearl Davis on the show
how about that yes please do guys
national network yes yes I would love to
be on The View which one's your favorite
which one's your favorite out of the the
whoopier or is it Joy or
um I mean I'm not talking favorite
literal but I think I would like to have
a conversation with Joy or whatever your
name is oh I would also love to have a
conversation with the I actually like
her that the Asian chick I don't know
her name she's not too bad I like her
but I I saw some clips from her on child
support and like like she was saying how
single mothers should go spend their
money on um what do you call it uh they
should be able to spend the money from
child support on themselves and I just
like to Red Pill her a little bit on
child support wow I just like to you
know bring some stories ask her if she
really thinks this is fair yeah that's
not good at all because I mean they're
doing laws now they're trying to pass
and they're getting all been out of
shape that you gotta show proof of where
your money goes they don't like that
what would you change about
year route in life that you took when
you started podcasting and out would you
change anything that you've done
do you regret doing anything you did
when it comes to podcasting yeah and
life too oh and life
um I wish I didn't work and copier sales
for two years I wish I didn't do that
hey you know what you probably got good
people skills from it though yeah I know
I did but gosh I could have done sold
something else do you have nightmares
about that that was a horrible I saw a
long distance one see that's how old I
am like Kevin Samuels yeah he he
actually worked I didn't know him okay
okay but he was working for Worldcom I
worked for the same company okay that's
how long did I did that that was a
nightmare we used to go to offices and
companies to to sell long distance see
this is before cell phones and mobile
phones that's how old I am but so you
have nightmares about copier sales yeah
yeah I wish yeah now that DocuSign
yeah they do you'd have to deal with it
I don't know the paperwork the way they
had the paperwork was so disorganized
like I I just couldn't stand corporate
because I just kept thinking like there
has to be a better way to do this stuff
and they didn't like me in corporate
because I would go to my boss and say
why do we do it this way like why don't
we use this software this make
everything easier and so then he would
be like I don't know so then I go to my
boss's boss and say the same thing and
then I go to my boss's boss's boss
nobody would listen to me you know do
you remember the original movie you're
probably too young Office Space the
movie no so you need to watch that you
don't watch movies and not really God
you're fired you gotta watch movies uh
yeah okay if you watch the original
Jennifer Aniston's in it okay okay it's
called office space it's a movie and and
You're gonna laugh because you're gonna
remember this podcast I told you to
watch it and you're gonna go oh my God
that was me that was me at Corporate
America yeah they they weren't I mean
and I I quit because I'm such a woman I
quit because they they said um I
couldn't I wanted to help them with
their media this is when I started like
looking at media and they said I
couldn't make like um videos at work
anymore even though I had more calls
than the other guys so I was like I have
my
said I hated the job anyway so I just
quit I was like yeah I gotta go off to
London yeah no I didn't I moved home and
then I just I told my parents I was
unemployed I was like I'm gonna be a
tick tocker and that's how you started
yeah that's how I started I didn't and
then covet happened I was supposed to go
to London so I was delayed by a year I
lived at home for a year so how long
have you had your YouTube channel
um I think in 2020 I started it the show
I started like a year ago
wow yeah you just now question yes you
talk about demonetization yes now you're
referring to not getting paid but you're
not referring to being like throttled
down or Shadow band
oh no I don't believe in Shadow Banner
you don't no I think that's like kind of
an excuse really yeah see I I think
that's the case sometimes yeah the only
time I've ever been actually shadow band
is when they age restricted that's real
Shadow Banning well now they ask you all
these questions do you see that they
changed it where like you post a video
and you say it's not for children and
then they want you to to rate your your
your video and then they have all these
categories it's like oh my gosh am I
said are you setting me up to not get
views
I don't think so wow I don't know I
don't do the the monetization stuff like
I I have a team yeah how many how many
people are on your team oh gosh 10 15.
how many you think work
but with the Clippers how many
something 20 something you got 27 people
20 something I don't know what I mean if
you count like contractors and
everything okay so you have an editing
team yes a product you run the
production team
kind of blessing does a bit of he
started off as like producing but now he
he kind of helped me with like
everything wow I would say blessings
like man so you're telling me it takes a
20 person team to run just for other
things
yes yes so are you high maintenance is
she high maintenance can you answer that
[Laughter]
what
no that's good though see you see that
that's how because when you start out
you're doing all your own work yeah I
did everything not a pain in the butt
yeah I outsourced like I honestly paid
other people before I paid myself do you
do you so you have somebody you have
social media manager running your your
Instagram no I do my own Instagram okay
they just do the YouTube stuff okay I do
my own IG yeah but I'm not I don't have
the the swag like you have but do you
think I have swag yeah dude you got 20
people running your your stuff Oh I
thought you meant my Instagram I'm like
my Instagram game is bad I'm not but you
got kicked off Tick Tock and Instagram I
got kicked off Tick Tock yeah but I have
a cheat code now I figured it out so
tell me I've been kicked off five times
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna after we get
off okay I'll tell you because I'm not a
fan of Tick Tock but I know how to break
the okay yeah yeah they kicked me off
too I'm back yeah right and you know
what's interesting I don't I don't know
if I should bring this up but I will
it's Chinese zoned right yeah if anybody
they they oppress women
and I'm not talking about bad stuff on
Tick Tock I had a lady do a blast on me
you know
um I don't know what you want to call it
but she put her video on there with me
and she's like this guy he's a cheese
dick blah blah blah this and this and
this and she posted it I thought it was
funny so I went to repost it and they
blocked it and I wanted to repost it
again and they said they blocked it and
then I go okay well I'm gonna go ask her
to get hers removed and they didn't
remove it I'm like how does that work
that's what happened the first time
because I almost had a million followers
on Tick Tock because this was and then
you know what's funny my audience used
to be 80 women ah
wait were you doing the same content
you're doing now no no I did all this
other stuff it actually sometimes like
backfired a bit because they'd find an
old clip and think it was serious when
it was like kind of like a skit or
something right yeah so they'll be like
oh my God Pearl did that like no it was
just to be funny but yeah but no I did
um
I did
I had I did Tick Tock before YouTube so
I um
yeah I almost had a million followers
and then I called the girl a whale
because she called me a slack and I
didn't know what a slag yeah it's like a
British term I didn't know either it's a
British term for horse I was like okay
well you're you're a whale clearly and
so yeah and then they they banned me
when I was just responding as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible